تعقد اليوم جلسه الاستماع الاولى للشهود
والمتهمه نيكول روجرز بقتل ممتعه السعودي
وليد الغريبي في فلادلفيا ياتي هذا بعد
تاجيل الجلسه بسبب الادله والمحامين بحسب
والد الغريبي هذا ورفضت محكمه ولاديلفيا
في وقت سابق الافراج المؤقت عن المتهمه
الامريكيه
وطالبت باستمرار احتجازها لدى الشرطه الى
ان يتم محاكمتها وكان الطالب الغريبي قد
قتل على يد روجرز التي تسكن في احد طوابق
منزله بعد اغتياله وسرقته في يناير الماضي
تقرير للشرطه الامريكيه حينها كشف بان
المتهمه ليست طالبه في الجامعه وانما
مدمنه مخدرات
من بلدها بولايه بنسلفانيا الامريكيه
مراسل العربيه حسين الطوط مساء الخير حسين
مرحبا بك معي في نشاط الرابع من الرياض
بدايه اخر
التطورات حول هذه الجلسه ما الذي يمكن
كذلك ان يحدث فيها جلسه الاستماع الاولى
لهذه القضيه ولماذا اجلت اصلا الى اليوم
تحيه لك نايف بالفعل انا امام المحكمه
الان هذه الجلسه هي الجلسه الاولى حيث
ستحضر المتهمه
وايضا شهوده منهم صاحبه المنزل الذي كان
يسكن فيه وليد الغريبه اضافه ربما ايضا
الى جار نيكول الذي سمع الضجيج عندما قتلت
وليد واتصل بصاحبه المنزل عندما اتينا هنا
لاحظنا ايضا وجود تمثيل للقنصليه العامه
السعوديه في نيويورك عبر نائب القنصل
العامه لماذا تاجلت الجلسه بحسب ما فهمنا
ان الاسباب لها علاقه بجمع الادله اضافه
الى امور روتينيه متعلقه بتاثير جائحه
كورونا على سير الاعمال اعمال
الوكالات الحكوميه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا هو السبب الرئيسي حتى
البارحه تحدثت الى والد الطالب وليد
الغريبي وقال لي بانه المحققون كانوا
يجمعون الادله خلال الاشهر الاربعه لذلك
تاجلت الجلسه الاولى من شهر ادله جديده
ستظهر في هذه الجلسة إلى يومنا هذا
بالفعل هذا ما اخبرني اياه والد الغريبي
قال ان هناك ادله وهناك امور ستتضح خلال
هذه الجلسه اليوم لان المحققين كانوا
يعملون على مدار الاشهر الاربعه لجمع هذه
الادله سالتها هل كان هناك تعاون بينك
وبينهم التواصل معهم كان
ليس لانه وليد او لانه هذه القضيه نفسها
لكن بسبب كثره الجرائم في مدينه فيلادلفيا
هنا نسبه الجريمه مرتفعه جدا المحققون
يتعاملون مع جرائم بشكل يومي لهذا السبب
ايضا ربما تاخرت الجلسه الاستماع الاولى
الى يومنا هذا سالته ماذا يتوقع
شعرت انه كان مترددا قليلا لا يريد التحدث
قال لننتظر الى يوم غد اي اليوم لنرى ماذا
سيكون هناك ما هي الادله التي سيعلن عنها
المحققون وماذا سيقول شهود العيان الذين
لا يتواجدوا ومنهم كما قلت صاحبه المنزل
حيث كان المغدور يسكن في لدى
حسين اذا كان هناك نسبه جرائم عاليه في
بلاديلفيا وبالتالي هذه القضيه ربما انها
يعني ليست المره الاولى التي تحدث قضيه
مثل هذه في بزلفينيا لان نسبه الجريمه
فيها مرتفعه وبالتالي نسال عن العقوبه
المتوقعه في مثل هذه الحاله
العقوبه هناك بالنسبه يعني اذا كنت تسال
عن عقوبه الاعدام على سبيل المثال هذه
العقوبه تختلف من ولايه الى ولايه هناك 25
ولايه تنفذها و25 ولايه تجرب عقوبه
الاعدام ولايه بنسلفانيا تحديدا اعاده
العمل بعقوبه الاعدام عام 1978 ولكن منذ
ذلك الوقت عام 72 وحتى يومنا هذا نفذت
عقوبه الاعدام بثلاثه اشخاص فقط لكي تنفذ
هذه العقوبه يجب ان يكون هناك اثبات على
ان المدعي عليه قد ارتكب جريمه من الدرجه
الاولى الان لكي يثبت ذلك على نيكول هذه
امر يتطلب وقت طويل ربما تستغرق الامور
اكثر من اكثر من سنه ويجب ان يكون هناك
تقديم ادله قاطعه اضافه الى موضوع
الاستئناف ورفض الاستئناف هي ليست مساله
سهله كما ان حاكم الولايه شابيرو كان تعهد
في فبراير الماضي بانه لن يوقع على اي امر
لتنفيذ الاعدام خلال فتره ولايته
بان تنضم
فينيا الى الولايات الخمسه والعشرين التي
تجرم تنفيذ عقوبه الاعدام كما قلت هناك في
المقابل من يدعو الى الاستمرار بعقوبه
الاعدام بسبب نسبه الجريمه المرتفعه وهناك
من يدعو الى الغائها مثل حاكم ولايه
بنسلفانيا اشكرك جزيل الشكر من بلاد فيها
بولايه الامريكيه مراسل العربيه